[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de France 24 empezamos Este
programa en la ciudad francesa de arles
con uno de los mayores acontecimientos
del patrimonio fotográfico mundial del 4
de julio al 25 de septiembre la edición
número 53 de los encuentros de la
fotografía reúne a decenas de artistas
que vienen a ofrecer al público su
visión del mundo y dentro de las 40
exposiciones presentadas este año una
trata de un tema cargado de activismo la
serie Los guardianes del agua de Bruno
segalunga que documentó entre 2017 y
2019 la lucha de los aborígenes de
Estados Unidos contra los proyectos de
dos oleoductos el
dakotain y el bayo bridgeline El
fotógrafo diálogo con nuestra colega de
la cadena hermana en francés los Maná
para contar Por qué decidió trabajar
sobre este tema Qué papel puede tener un
artista en las luchas sociales lo
escuchamos
trabajo de una manera bastante orgánica
es decir muchas veces las series nacen
de una serie anterior
2016 Estuvo trabajando mucho en Francia
contra ese proyecto de aeropuerto junto
a la ciudad de nantes y allí fue donde
me enteré de lo que estaba ocurriendo en
la reserva indígena de standing Rock
se llama Y así fue como me interesé en
este tema porque visimilitudes en el
hecho de intentar vivir de otra manera
de primer otro modelo de sociedad más
igualitario
deshaciéndose del estado en notre Dame
similitudes con lo que intentaban los
nativos americanos para ellos la
instalación de un oleoducto cerca de la
reserva o por debajo de sus tierras de
reserva supone la ruptura por parte del
Estado Federal de los tratados firmados
durante el siglo 18 con las naciones
indias que les otorgan autonomía sobre
sus propias tierras
[Música]
hago fotografía que se puede llamar
militante Son obras de arte y reivindico
esta condición de obra de arte para
estas fotografías pero también Son obras
que deben demostrar algo reivindicar
algo y en particular esta desigualdad
siempre trabajo sobre luchas asimétricas
es decir que son individuos o colectivos
los que luchan contra el estado y casi
nunca se puede ganar sobre el terreno
porque el estado tiene una fuerza
policial un ejército que puede enviar
sobre todo en Estados Unidos y ganará
inevitablemente por otro lado después
las luchas pueden ser victorias en el
ámbito judicial me interesa un cierto
tipo de fotografía en la que desde los
años 20 y 30 El fotógrafo se sumerge en
la sociedad para informar sobre ella y
esperar que a largo plazo desaparezcan
las desigualdades
y en Bolivia otra fiesta cultural abrió
sus puertas al público la Feria
Internacional del Libro de la paz hasta
el 14 de agosto la edición número 26 de
este evento cultural le hace honor a las
lenguas indígenas y aporte femenino a la
literatura y en efecto de la treintena
de autores invitados el 70% son
escritoras la organización de la feria
esperaba acoger a unos 100.000
visitantes en este evento que ofrece más
de 400 actividades culturales en otras
buenas noticias una de las joyas de la
ciudad de Estambul en Turquía acaba de
reabrirse al público la cisterna
basílica del emperador justinió tras
cinco años de intensas obras destinadas
a protegerla de un eventual terremoto
Los visitantes regresaron para descubrir
este edificio subterráneo de 1500 años
de antigüedad con una experiencia aún
más espectacular ahora Gracias a una
nueva escenografía de sonidos y luces
bajo los focos encontramos también esta
semana a la estrella estadounidense de
la música Beyoncé que estrenó su muy
esperado séptimo álbum una mezcla de pop
hip hop afro y House perfecto para
provocar Euforia en las pistas de baile
Pero también es objeto de una ola de
críticas y ataques Beyoncé quizás deba
grabar de nuevo unos de sus temas
[Música]
en nosotros estemos musicales de la
semana los mucho menos polémicos y
irlandeses de tudor Cinema Club están de
vuelta con Lucky un tema extraído del
próximo álbum de la Banda pop Rock
para principios de septiembre
[Música]
en un estilo bien diferente rapero
francés Gandhi estreno el divertido ptt
con una melodía que tiene sabor a los
clubes de los años 2000 por utilizar la
icónica canción calabria
[Música]
y nos despedimos con la colaboración
entre el DJ canadiense que trata y el
cantante y músico estadounidense
Anderson
Gracias a ustedes por su confianza
[Música]
pequeña